why was Disney so obsessed with turning
people into bears they did it in brother
bear which didn't do so well it is in
brother bear to which as far as I know
didn't do so well even Pixar didn't
brave which also didn't do so well did
one of the Disney higher-ups just want
to be a bear well whatever the reason we
have this direct-to-dvd sequel that big
shock is not very good if you saw my
review of the first one you know I like
everything in the beginning everything
in the end and think the middle was
really dumb I guess that's better than
this one seeing how it's mostly dumb and
pointless and forced and uncomfortable
and I should get to it a young woman is
about to marry a young man in this
arranged marriage but God literally
splits them apart because apparently
they weren't meant for each other or at
least the sassy medicine woman played by
Wanda Sykes says that long ago she gave
her heart to someone else when they were
little kids well of course that little
kid was our main character from the last
one who's a bear now but the sassy magic
Wanda Sykes gives her the speech of the
bear Oh
after they mixed up with some other
wacky animals ha ha don't know if she
can talk with the bear and they have to
work together to burn this amulet of
course they do nothing but bicker and
argue and act like they don't like each
other and where is this going
surely they're going to hate each other
throughout the whole thing right oh oh
the sassy little cub from the last month
way to truth lies ants in these movies
hate the fact that he might be falling
in love with her so he tries to
jeopardize the relationship but oh oh
the children would also want to fall in
love with these two Lady moose this is
what's the plural I don't care it's a
dumb movie will they be able to show
them how to win over the ladies we'll
also acting cool at the same time oh
wait a minute they're not acting cool
they should just learn to be themselves
and follow their heart and all sorts of
other cliches you've heard a million
times but doesn't add anything new to it
that's all it is it's just cliches from
kids movies romantic comedies bland
adventure tales with nothing charming or
fresh thrown on top of it you're just
watching these cliches play out and
nothing
cliches are fine we need them once in a
while but if you're not going to add
anything or give a unique spin on it
it's just cliches and nothing else the
world they inhabit doesn't even make
sense
like our right to be knows that the main
character is turned into a bear yet at
the end the cub goes into the village
and they're like oh no they'll kill him
well why would they kill him don't they
know that he's a guy I'll turn into a
bear anyone he goes in there they're all
trying to hunt him down and kill him
she's like no no no but wait don't they
know it'll cover that there's a bear
wedding Sen where there's all these
people and all the animals on both sides
and clearly may know why were they
hunting each other a day ago I'd be like
screw you guys I'm not going to your
wedding look at me hold all right so
yeah this movie's pretty stupid but is
there anything good to it oh I guess
I'll be enough a couple things one
there's no Phil Collins good start -
this is probably the best looking out
the Disney sequels I've seen so far not
only does the animation pretty much look
identical to the first film but the
backgrounds are gorgeous look at those
brush strokes look at how thick they are
they stand out but they also blend
together just right and they really help
the characters in the foreground stick
out well again also kind of blending
together on top of that it's also kind
of feels the most cinematic it's paced
well and it's acted well and it's
animated well and it looks great really
the biggest problem is just the writing
but yeah that's a really big problem
it's just characters acting like they
know what to do and then it turns out
they don't know what to do and then they
throw in some catch phrases and look the
moose as a like Canadians do because get
it they're from Canada it's just generic
and dumped and doesn't add up I guess I
can't say it's the worst because we have
movies like Mulan - and Beauty and the
Beast three and such to me those are
much more offensive this is just stupid
and once again not deserving of this
great animation and this wonderful
background work I don't know if you're a
fan of the first one maybe you'll like
this one but it's kind of hard for me to
find people are even fans
first one there just kind of forgotten
Disney movies that for some reason they
throw a lot of effort into just not the
best writing not the worst but
definitely pretty bad
[Music]
you